chiusura tout le monde
[Applauso]
siamo sul pil c'è il 69 episodio ragazzi
mammamia arriveremo a 200 un giorno
abbiamo fatto un sacco di livelli finora
mai fatto un album da oggi questa la
prima volta non sto scherzando
ovviamente abbiamo mai pur 3 perché vi
ne ha fatti un sacco quindi insomma
facciamo un occhio non mi dici dove
arrivano aiuto vabbè vabbè bellissimo
nov aveva fatto da dio ragazzi aiuto non
ho giorno io li appunto oggi cio non
solo livelli grazie all itc del mondo è
che attori livelli pensionistici del
mondo perché noi come capire la
direzione 2000 posizionare però va bene
bellissimo matrix madonna che quanto
fatto bene scrive l'aiuto madonna che
schivata incredibile meno ma basta basta
che ansia quanto tempo per schivare
tutta sta roba
ma basta tutto bene tranquilli mi fai un
altro oddio ma era una trovata che è
pigro bellissimo ma che livello in
credito a zia sei un genio fatto dire
sei un genio non avrei mai i miei
scritti ma bravo penso
nella top five dei livelli migliori e
pierce che abbia mai fatto
nel nella ricerca settimanale ovviamente
perché sennò no però del bellissimo
belli c'è ancora gente che si fa un culo
così a per fare le verifiche più bravi
con quale voglia laser bim tempo guarise
l'espace start un dumper che vince un
caso fa casino fa megabit mele
ma che figo no è piacevole sentire il
rumore e così è quasi non smr ragazzi
persone che non sono iscritte all ha
detto liu bastano suarez non si sa se
non siete iscritti ma cosa ve lo dico a
fare ma ragazzi è un livello bellissimo
ma cosa è successo sono aiutare gli
esperti di fare livelli di f.liszt
adesso c'è da un momento all'altro
epicità di livelli h caso vabbè è bello
comunque non ho geniale geniale 10 scola
earthquake toilette per ora cavalca il
terremoto
il terremoto terremoto sulle api visione
storia che a muovermi
luke occhio ai a io che schiattato
tesoro è fa niente sono molto chi va
bene fa niente devo capire come ci
arrivo dall altra l'obiettivo arrivare
dall'altra parte del livello dopo di noi
sa fare neanche un metro e proprio la
difficoltà nel muovermi incredibile vai
veloce ho fatto un metro
pazzesco io già sto tornando indietro
fammi andare avanti basta
e vabbè è volato la panchina no vabbè
era impossibile ma vi giuro non mai vi
stanno proprio sotto natalia linee
bastava vai avanti
porca vacca ma ce la farò una fine soli
da perfetto mi butto sotto accada sono
morto un secondo dopo ma l'ho toccata va
bene bordo philippe rainbow provare che
va detto non avrei più fatto robot ma ci
provo lo diamo a travaglio un tiro solo
no questo è carino perché c'è un sacco
di posti dove può finire il bottino
quindi occhio buono alla vittoria stalin
e il blu ok la ci prova dai questo etico
è una sorta di bottle flip boltro un
botto trovo bellissimo ultrà ma poi ma
come devo farlo arrivare su vittoria sta
quello blu ma sai che non lo metterò mai
ma con demonio e proprio imprendibile
c'è prendo sempre pro master gold
emerald ma non prendo vittoria che
stalin mlg c'ero quasi vedi master
proprio lì bio easy e proprio wing e
allora
ma dai ma dai basta rock swing che vinco
sempre almeno quelli ecco non cercate
guarda
lasciamo perdere ma il meglio che devo
stare io devo stare solo zitto nella mia
visita
ecco infatti lode tutto bene ora la ok
mamma mia ragazzi ma che giocatore ma
che giocatore è
ma che il giocatore è impulsiva ogni
possible oggi almeno ci sta così è un
impulsivo da lancio no se avessi vinto
subito la partita ma da un sapere parola
cioè prima duke no scherzavo il che è
già pronto porca vacca se difficile però
se mi impegno forse cds madonna quanto
difficile farli tutti
ma dai madonna impegnare un sacco da dio
mio
vabbè madonna o ieri proprio oggi
proprio nava ma che è che non è così
difficile teoricamente lo schiacciare
solo il momento giusto tipo adesso hanno
vinto le mie gambe
eccolo madonna
il finale non è stato proprio set i
sistemi di vendita
chissenefrega pin ruggedized bellissimo
presso il re di sono pronto è una specie
di addio aiuto non mi ha schiacciato per
miracolo
che ti devo sopravvivere agli oggetti
che cascano madonna ma che livelli
incredibili in stan facendo ragazzi oggi
oggi partitone già oggi video
incredibile finirà maisto livello che
devo fare ad un sì amici che lo
schiaccia regola roba può essere la roba
che sta nel mezzo
era semplicemente il coso che portava il
lampadario sono vivo mi basta quanto
dura al suo livello basta eccolo aiap
aiap un tavolino nel collo cosa devo
fare
ma c'è sito perché aspettare ritorniamo
in piedi vediamo se non finisce ho visto
io a quindi non dello non ha un finale
ok adesso stupido io che stavo continua
dall'infinito va bene minchia è
difficilissimo o vito che vittoria
strana ragazzi proprio attenzione queste
buono cav h che bello sto impossible
va bene sono successe cose ma fa niente
salta veloce e pieno di tra proprio dove
centrare solo la vittoria il che è
veramente difficile molto bene questa
mappa ti odia e io odio lavato ma non ho
capito bass ma è insieme a ian ma come è
ma a volte luke non me la finke odia uk
allora ci parliamo la stessa lingua
ma devo andare all'indietro che ci sono
delle trappole che tu non che tu devi
scoprire praticamente giusto qua
immagino diedero sapevo a ok fighissimo
o da quando ai primi sei diventato gioco
incredibile non lo so è quindi cosa che
devo fare devo aspettare
sai che è successo qua e ho capito e se
passo muoio cosa devo fare qua scusa ma
è l'unica forse sai che ho capito cosa
devo fare per levare la se ho capito
ragazzi voglio veramente un premio nobel
per la scienza
vediamo se ho capito è veramente come
devo fare così
scommetti no no sorride map maker it
system ok ok autrice della morte fine
non c'è una fine ok va bene però devo
fare così avete visto che ho ragione tra
non va bene facciamo l'ultimo che di the
spy polverini be nice
[Applauso]
ecco però male ma non è madonna ma come
passò di lì ma non è per easy ma mi hai
preso per i fondelli
ma non è ma non è verissima ai nella
vita scusami ma come faccio a fare sta
roba di testa di keita no ma ragazzi
impossibile non saprò mai stai
scherzando
buonissimo questo è buono visto come
buono come calcolo bene io ragazzi in
mamma mia
perfetto bello questo livello che ho
perso
fantastico proprio così voglio vincere
io morendo scusami un attimo perché non
ho capito come possibile ma veramente
c'è praticamente devo rimanere
drittissimo ma qua ma neanche no ma non
si può fare ragazzo ebbe risi non esiste
vi odio
spero che video vi sia piaciuto no
ragazzi mi sono mi arrendo uno dei pochi
livelli di emissioni dove mi arrendo
mamma mia bravi sia piaciuto ragazzi
come se il momento è un mi piace anche
perché come vito come sempre state
nella descrizione era il ragga suoli ci
vediamo allora seguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]
no